all right so I want you to imagine that
you get a text from a friend and it
reads you will not believe what just
happened I'm so mad right now so you do
the dutiful thing as a friend and you
ask for details and they tell you a
story about what happened to them at the
gym or at work or on their day last
night and you listen and you try to
understand why they're so mad maybe even
secretly judge whether or not they
should be so mad and maybe even offer
some suggestions now in that moment you
were doing essentially what I get to do
every day because I'm an anger
researcher and as an anger researcher I
spend a good part of my professional
life Who am I kidding also my personal
life studying why people get mad I study
the types of thoughts they have when
they get mad and I even study what they
do when they get mad whether it's
getting into fights or breaking things
or even yelling at people in all caps on
the internet and as you can imagine when
people hear I'm an anger researcher they
want to talk to me about their anger
they want to share with me their anger
stories it's not because they need a
therapist though that does sometimes
happen it's really because anger is
universal it's something we all feel and
it's something they can relate to we've
been feeling it since the first few
months of life when we didn't get what
we wanted and our cries of protests
things like what do you mean you won't
pick up the rattle dad I want it
we feel it throughout our teenage years
as my mom can certainly attest you with
me sorry mom
we feel it to the very end in fact anger
has been with us at some of the worst
moments of our lives
it's a natural and expected part of our
grief but it's also been with us at some
of the best moments of our lives with
those special occasions like weddings
and vacations often marred by these
everyday frustrations bad weather travel
delays that feel horrible in the moment
but then are ultimately forgotten when
things go okay so I have a lot of
conversations with people about their
anger and is through those conversations
that I've learned that many people and I
bet many people in this room right now
you see anger as a problem you see the
way it interferes in your life the way
it damages relationships maybe even the
ways it's scary and while I get all of
that I see anger a little differently
and today I want to tell you something
really important about your anger and
it's this anger is a powerful and
healthy force in your life it's good
that you feel it you need to feel it but
to understand all that we actually have
to back up and talk about why we get mad
in the first place and a lot of this
comes back to the work from of an anger
researcher named dr. Jerry dieffenbachia
who wrote about this back in 1996 in a
book chapter on how to deal with
problematic anger no for most of us and
I bet most of you it feels as simple as
this I get mad when I'm provoked right
you heard in the language people use
they say things like it makes me so mad
when people drive this slow or I got mad
because she left the milk out again well
my favorite I don't have an anger
problem people just need to stop messing
with me now in the spirit of better
understanding those types of
provocations I asked a lot of people
including my friends and colleagues and
even family one of the things that
really get to you what makes you mad and
by the way now's a good time to point
out one of the advantages of being an
anger researcher is that I've spent more
than a decade generating a comprehensive
list of all the things that really
irritate my call colleagues right just
in case I need it
but their answers are fascinating
because they say things like when my
sports team loses people who chew too
loudly that is surprisingly common by
the way people who walk too slowly that
one's mine
and of course roundabouts right
roundabouts I can tell you honestly
there is no rage like roundabouts rage
sometimes their answers aren't minor at
all
sometimes they talk about racism and
sexism and bullying and environmental
destruction big global problems we all
face but sometimes their answers are
very specific maybe even oddly specific
that wet line you get across your shirt
when you accidentally lean against the
counter of a public bathroom super gross
right or flash drives so make two ways
to plug them in so why does it always
take me three tries now whether it's
minor or major whether it's general or
specific we can look at these examples
and we can tease out some common themes
right we get angry in situations that
are unpleasant that feel unfair where
our goals are blocked that could have
been avoided and that leave us feeling
powerless this is a recipe for anger but
you can also tell that anger is probably
not the only thing we're feeling in
these situations right anger doesn't
happen in a vacuum we can feel angry at
the same time that we're scared or sad
or feeling a host of other emotions but
here's the thing these provocations they
aren't making us mad at least not on
their own and we know that because if
they were we'd all get angry over the
same things and we don't the reasons I
get angry are different than the reasons
you get angry so there's got to be
something else going on what is that
something else where we know what we're
doing and feeling at the moment of that
provocation matters we call this the pre
anger State are you hungry are you tired
are you anxious about something else are
you running late for something when
you're feeling those things those
provocations feel that much worse but
what matters most
it's not the provocation it's not the
pre anger state it's this it's how we
interpret that provocation how we make
sense of it in our lives when was
something happens to us we first decide
is this good or bad is it fair or unfair
is it blameworthy is it punishable this
primary appraisal is when you evaluate
the event itself and we decide what it
means in the context of our lives and
then once we've done that we decide how
bad it is that's secondary appraisal
right we say is this the worst thing
that's ever happened or can I cope with
this now to illustrate that I want you
to imagine you are driving somewhere and
before I go any further I should tell
you if I were an evil genius and I
wanted to create a situation that was
gonna make you mad that situation would
look a lot like driving it's true you
are by definition on your way somewhere
so everything that happens traffic other
drivers road construction it feels like
it's blocking your goals there's all
there are all these written and
unwritten rules of the road and those
rules are routinely violated right in
front of you usually without consequence
and who's violating those rules
anonymous others people you will never
see again making them a very easy target
for your wrath so you're driving
somewhere thus teed up to be angry and
the person in front of you is driving
well below the speed limit and it's
frustrating because you can't really see
why they're driving so slow right that's
primary appraisal you've looked at this
and you've said it's bad in this
blameworthy but maybe you also decide
it's not that big a deal you're not in a
hurry doesn't matter that secondary
appraisal you don't get angry but now
imagine you're on your way to a job
interview what that person is doing it
hasn't changed right so primary
appraisal doesn't change still bad still
blameworthy but your ability to cope
with it sure does because all of a
sudden you're gonna be late to that job
interview all of a sudden you are not
gonna get your dream job the one that
was gonna give you piles and piles of
money right
somebody else is gonna get your dream
job and you're gonna be broke you're
gonna be destitute I might as well stop
now turn around move in with your
parents why because of this person in
front of me specially this is not a
person this is a monster and this
monster is here just to ruin your life
know that thought process
it's called catastrophizing the one
where we make the worst of things and
it's one of the primary types of
thoughts that we know is associated with
chronic anger but there's a couple of
others mister tripping causation angry
people tend to put blame where it
doesn't belong not just on people but
actually inanimate objects as well and
if you think that sounds ridiculous
think about the last time you lost your
car keys and you said where did those
car keys go right because you know they
ran off on their own
they tend to over generalize they use
words like always
never every this always happens to me I
never get what I want or I hit every
stoplight on the way here today
demandingness they put their own needs
ahead of the needs of others I don't
care why this person is driving so slow
they need to speed up or move over so I
can get to this job interview and
finally inflammatory labeling they call
people fools idiots monsters or a whole
bunch of things I've been told I'm not
allowed to say during this TED talk so
for a long time psychologists have
referred to these as cognitive
distortions or even irrational beliefs
and yeah sometimes they are irrational
maybe even most the time but sometimes
these thoughts are totally rational
there is unfairness in the world there
are cruel selfish people and it's not
only okay to be angry when we're treated
poorly it's right to be angry when we're
treated poorly now if there's one thing
I want you to remember from my talk
today it's this your anger exists in you
as an emotion because it offered your
ancestors both human and non-human with
an evolutionary advantage it's one just
as your fear alerts you to danger your
anger alerts you to injustice it's one
of the
your brain communicates to you that you
have had enough what's more it energizes
you to confront that injustice think for
a second about the last time you got mad
your heart rate increased your breathing
increased you started to sweat
that's your sympathetic nervous system
otherwise known as your fight or flight
system kicking you excuse me kicking in
to offer you the energy you need to
respond and that's just the stuff you
noticed at the same time your digestive
system it slowed down so you can
conserve energy that's why your mouth
went dry and your blood vessels dilated
to get muscle to get blood to your
extremities that's why your face went
red it's all part of this complex
pattern of physiological experiences
that exist today because they helped
your ancestors deal with cruel and
unforgiving forces of nature and the
problem is that the thing your ancestors
did to deal with their anger to
physically fight they're no longer
reasonable or appropriate you can't and
you shouldn't swing a club every time
you're provoked but here's the good news
you are capable of something your
nonhuman ancestors weren't capable of
and that is the capacity to regulate
your emotions even when you want to lash
out you can stop yourself and you can
channel that anger into something more
productive so often when we talk about
anger we talk about how to keep from
getting angry we tell people to calm
down or relax we even tell people to let
it go and all of that assumes that anger
is bad and that it's wrong to feel it
but instead I like to think of anger as
a motivator the same way your thirst
motivates you to get a drink of water
the same way your hunger motivates you
to get a bite to eat your anger can
motivate you to respond to injustice
because we don't have to think too hard
to find things we should be mad about
when we go back to the beginning yeah
some of those things they're silly and
not worth getting angry over a racism
sexism bullying environmental
destruction those things are real those
things are terrible in the only way to
fix them is to get mad first and then
channel that anger into fighting back
and you don't have to fight back with
aggression or hostility or violence
there are infinite ways that you can
express your anger you can protest you
can write letters to the editor you can
donate to and volunteer for causes you
create art you can create literature you
can create poetry and music you can
create a community that cares from one
another and does not allow those
atrocities to happen so the next time
you feel yourself getting angry instead
of trying to turn it off I hope you'll
listen to what that anger is telling you
and then I hope you'll channel it into
something positive and productive thank
you